* Glockengebimmel *
Er hat etwas
von einem religiösen Disneyland:
der Park Otradnoje,
nicht unweit von meinem
Korrespondentenbüro in Moskau.
* Kehliger Gebetsgesang *
Hier bietet die Stadt Platz
für geistliche Gebäude
verschiedenster Religionen -
ein Symbol dafür,
dass heute in Russland
religiöse Vielfalt herrscht.
Von der russisch-orthodoxen Kirche
bis zum Schamanismus.
Das war nicht immer so.
In den 70er-Jahren
der kommunistischen Sowjetunion
waren Religionen verpönt
und Gläubige wurden unterdrückt.
* Gebete *
* Glockenbimmeln *
Seit dem Zusammenbruch
der Sowjetunion
spriessen
die unterschiedlichsten Religionen.
Die faszinierende Vielfalt
interessiert mich.
Darum fliege ich 5'000 km nach Osten,
zum Baikalsee.
Dort liegt die Insel Olchon, die
wie kaum ein anderer Ort Russlands
für ihre Spiritualität bekannt ist -
und nebenbei wunderschön sein soll.
Die einheimische Fahrerin Daria
bringt uns zur Insel.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen, Daria?
Was macht Olchon aus?
Olchon ist ein heiliger,
ein magischer Ort.
Ein Ort, an dem Wünsche in Erfüllung
gehen und man in Harmonie lebt.
War das gerade Werbung?
Nein, es ist tatsächlich so.
* Leichter A-cappella-Gesang *
Eine lange religiöse Tradition
soll es hier geben,
habe ich oft von Russen gehört.
Wie wird diese heute gelebt?
Dieser Frage will ich nachgehen.
Regisseurin Corinne Eisenring
begleitet mich bei den Dreharbeiten.
1'500 Menschen wohnen hier,
die meisten leben immer noch
vom Fischfang - oder vom Tourismus.
Uff. Uiuiui.
Seit Jahren wird hier wieder
frei Schamanismus praktiziert.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Über Religion oder Geistlichkeit
habe ich schon
mehrere Fernsehbeiträge gemacht.
Einmal sogar über Exorzismus.
Das sind heikle Themen.
Über Sinn oder Unsinn
möchte ich nicht richten.
Ich will erfahren, warum dieser Ort
für viele Menschen besonders ist.
"Aber wo anfangen?", frage ich mich.
"Lies doch die Inserate",
meint mein russischer Kameramann.
Tatsächlich: Schamanen und Geist-
heiler bieten hier ihre Dienste an.
Wie seriös das wohl ist?
Ein vierstündiger Ausflug
zu den Kraftorten der Insel.
Das wäre doch schon mal was.
(Mann)
Schau mal, wie viele Orte es gibt.
Knapp 100 Euro kostet der Ausflug.
Die Kraftorte
sind nicht gerade billig.
Doch das scheint mir
kein schlechter Einstieg zu sein.
Ljuba Kiriltschuk bietet
den Ausflug zu den Kraftorten an.
Hauptberuflich
arbeitet sie als Bibliothekarin.
Sehen Sie, wir haben
nur eine kleine Ecke zu Olchon.
Das ist eines der Bücher davon.
Über Olchon
haben Sie noch nichts geschrieben?
Nein, ich weiss nicht.
- Na los, schreiben Sie doch!
Ich habe einfach nicht genug Zeit,
ich hatte so viele andere Projekte.
Dieses Jahr habe ich es vor.
- Worüber wollen Sie denn schreiben?
Zuerst über die Sagen von Olchon.
Weil hier
die ältere Generation bereits stirbt
und es sehr viele
interessante Leute gegeben hat,
die Geschichten erzählen,
die tatsächlich so passiert sind.
Ljuba will mir Orte zeigen, an denen
ich magische Energien spüren werde.
Das ist die Strasse meiner Kindheit.
Dieses Eckhaus ist das Haus,
in dem ich aufgewachsen bin.
Als Erstes
bringt mich Ljuba zu einem Baum,
wo weibliche Energien
zu spüren seien.
Und wenn du hier stehst,
kommt von unten Wärme hoch.
Sogar wenn ein bisschen Schnee
liegt. Die Füsse werden wärmer.
Wieso wissen Sie,
dass das die weibliche Seite ist?
Weil ich viele Leute hierher bringe
und die mir das sagen.
* Sie spricht russisch. *
Hier spüre ich noch nichts.
Natürlich muss der Baum noch
eine starke, männliche Seite haben.
Die männliche Schulter. Lehn dich
mal etwas an und sag, was du fühlst.
(Corinne) Was fühlst denn du?
Ich habe mich nicht angelehnt.
Ist eher für Frauen gedacht.
Schauen Sie. Hier sind die Fähnchen
und das Häuschen.
Mitten im Wald: ein verstecktes
buddhistisches Gebetshäuschen.
* Helle Gitarrenklänge *
Beim Eintreten muss man entweder ein
Stäbchen oder eine Kerze anzünden
und dann so den Raum erleuchten.
Damit hier keine fremde Energie ist.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Wohin damit? - Sie können es
hierhin oder dorthin legen.
(Corinne) Wieso machst du das jetzt?
Sie sagt, man dürfe kein Geld geben,
aber etwas Süsses dalassen.
Für die Geister.
Und dann muss ich
genau an dieser Stelle innehalten.
Sie werden spüren, wie
die Energie die Beine hinabfliesst,
die Energie fliesst nach unten.
Und geht weg?
Ich bin selber
ein ganzes Jahr lang hergekommen.
Ich musste einige
schlechte Erinnerungen loswerden.
Also natürlich nicht jeden Tag,
aber oft.
Es gibt noch einen anderen Ort,
an dem Sie etwas spüren werden.
(Corinne) Spürst du etwas?
Das muss ich nachher sagen.
Da müsste man wohl alleine kommen
und sich bewusst darauf einlassen.
Aber jetzt merkst du nichts?
- Das ist ein Geheimnis.
Es wäre falsch, zu sagen, dass ich
hier eine grosse Erleuchtung hatte.
Es ist ... Da ist es noch einfacher,
Politkorrespondent zu sein.
Ich erkläre lieber die russische
Politik in Syrien oder der Ukraine,
als dir jetzt hier irgendwie ...
... von meinen Gefühlen
mit diesen Energien zu erzählen.
Es ist interessant hier.
Ich glaube, selbst wenn ich
die Energie spüren würde,
könnte ich das nicht so offen sagen.
Vielleicht,
die Menschen sind unterschiedlich.
Es kommen hauptsächlich
offene Menschen hierher,
weil sie Hilfe suchen und wissen,
dass diese Orte existieren.
Und sie bekommen Unterstützung.
Ich denke, was ich hier fühle,
nehme ich für mich persönlich mit.
Ich war gerne mit Ljuba unterwegs.
Es tut mir sogar ein bisschen leid,
dass ich die Energien
nicht so spüren konnte wie sie.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Zufällig findet bei unserem
Aufenthalt der Inselmarathon statt.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Und, wie läuft's?
- Hier bräuchte man Stöcke.
Und die Energie?
Ich rede mit mir selber
und mit dem Baikal.
Und was sagt er?
Dass ich bis ans Limit gehen soll,
ich muss es schaffen.
Er sagt, man müsse gutherzig sein
und sich von seinen Lastern befrei-
en, dann wird alles gut im Leben.
Weiter geht's.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Um diese typische Olchon-Energie
zu spüren,
war diese Läuferin
extra aus Moskau hergeflogen.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
* Glockenschläge *
Auf der Insel gibt es seit dem Jahr
2000 auch eine orthodoxe Kirche.
* Er singt ein Gebet auf Russisch. *
* Chorgesang *
Als Katholik fühle ich mich hier
auf vertrauterem Boden.
Trotzdem ist es speziell:
Die Messe dauert 2 Std.
* Chorgesang *
Die Gläubigen kommen und gehen.
Ich warte,
bis der Gottesdienst zu Ende ist,
um Pfarrer Wassili kennenzulernen.
* Der Chorgesang verklingt. *
Erfreut, guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Störe ich? - Nein, nein.
Kommen Sie, setzten wir uns doch.
Jetzt haben wir das schwierigste
Thema, die Spiritualität.
Ja, ja.
Die Spiritualität
lässt sich schwer beschreiben,
man kann das nur
auf eine primitive Art.
Aber die persönliche Religiosität,
die Erfahrung,
kann ein Mensch
nicht einem anderen weitergeben.
Jeder macht das für sich.
Wenn du an Gott glaubst, macht jeder
seine eigenen Erfahrungen.
Wassili ist aufgewachsen
während der Sowjetzeit,
als Religionen verboten
und verfolgt wurden.
Wie die meisten Russen
war er damals Atheist.
* Er spricht russisch. *
Als die Sowjetunion auseinanderfiel,
gab es eine Art Vakuum.
Es war ein Schwebezustand.
Du hattest das Gefühl,
dass du auf einer Plattform lebst,
und dann hat man diese Plattform
plötzlich entfernt.
Es war unklar,
wie du lebst, wofür du lebst.
Und zu dieser Zeit
habe ich angefangen,
in die Kirche zu gehen.
Sie hatten also diese Plattform
gegen den Glauben ausgetauscht?
Wir haben sie nicht ausgetauscht.
Der Mensch muss an etwas glauben.
Während der Sowjetunion
glaubten wir,
wir würden
eine strahlende Zukunft errichten.
Alle sechs Monate
verlässt Wassili die Insel.
Er besucht
all die Mitglieder seiner Gemeinde,
die in den entlegenen Dörfern
der Region leben.
Eine gute Gelegenheit,
um die abgelegensten Winkel
der Region kennenzulernen.
Meine Kollegin Corinne
hat ihn begleitet.
Die Strassen zu den Dörfern
sind schlecht.
Darum fährt Wassili mit seinem Freund
Sascha, der einen Jeep besitzt.
Es geht
mitten durch einen Nationalpark.
Sascha
fährt diese Strecke zum ersten Mal.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Das Ziel von Priester Wassili:
das Dorf Onguren.
Dort hat das Ehepaar Zelenin
eigenhändig eine Kapelle gebaut -
aus Trauer um seine Söhne.
Nach 4 Std. Fahrt
klappert der Jeep verdächtig laut.
Und tatsächlich: Der Tank
hängt nur noch locker am Jeep.
Wassili und Sascha improvisieren.
Das muss halten
für die ganze Strecke hin und zurück.
Das Gewand ist etwas unbequem,
aber das macht nichts.
Es hat Vor- und Nachteile.
Wenn man mit Menschen kommuniziert,
ist es einfacher,
die Kommunikation mit Behörden
ist einfacher.
Aber es ist keine Kleidung
für ein Abenteuer.
Das ist halt so eine Sache
mit diesem Gewand.
Nach zwei weiteren Stunden
erreicht Wassili das Dorf Onguren.
Doch die Kapelle liegt ausserhalb und
dorthin gibt es keine Strasse mehr.
Die Fahrt
geht direkt am Ufer entlang -
oder besser gesagt: übers Wasser.
Da ist Gottes Hilfe gefragt.
* Er betet auf Russisch. *
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Hallo, mein Teurer, ich bin froh,
dich zu sehen. Wie geht's?
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Für Anatoli und Ludmilla Zelenin
ist Priester Wassili
seit Monaten der erste Besucher.
Er bringt ihnen zwei Ikonen mit.
Mir wurde eine Ikone geklaut.
- Das macht nichts.
Oh, da ist es aber sauber.
Zwei Jahre lang hat das Ehepaar
an dieser Holzkapelle gebaut.
2005, 2006 haben sich zwei
unserer Söhne das Leben genommen.
Die Kapelle ist für sie, wir bitten
damit um Gnade für ihren Suizid.
Suizid ist ja Sünde.
* Wassili singt ein Gebet
auf Russisch. *
* Er spricht russisch. *
Was sein Besuch bedeutet?
V.a., dass ich hier
nicht vergessen bin.
Er kam extra hierher.
Um ehrlich zu sein, ich kann mich
ja kaum noch auf den Beinen halten.
Ja, er ist müde und ausgelaugt,
und er hat kein Benzin mehr.
Wassili kann helfen:
Er hat einen Benzinkanister
für den alten Traktor
aus sowjetischen Zeiten.
Wassili ist überzeugt,
dass Glaube und Spiritualität
die beiden Alten für ihr Leben
in der Abgeschiedenheit stärken.
Leb lang, werde nicht krank.
Nächstes Jahr komme ich wieder.
Doch auch die andere Seite
der Religion war hier spürbar.
Sie hinterlässt bei den Eltern
Schuldgefühle
wegen des Suizides ihrer Söhne.
* Sanfte, sphärische Klänge *
Einen,
den die Insel nicht mehr loslässt,
ist der französische Fotograf
Nicolas Pernot.
Er hat hier insgesamt
schon drei Jahre gelebt.
Die Insel ist für ihn
ein Ort von magischer Schönheit.
* Christof spricht russisch. *
Was für ein Prachtskerl.
Da weisst du nicht,
ob es ein Mann oder ein Baum ist.
Unser Ziel: das Kap Choboi.
Traumhaft für Nicolas Pernot.
Der nördlichste Punkt der Insel.
Halt, stopp, hier.
- Fahren wir weiter.
Ich gehe lieber die letzten Meter.
Das ist das Ende der Insel?
- Nein, dort ist das Ende.
Das ist also
der schönste Ort für dich.
Ja, er ist sehr hoch, sehr schön.
Gefällt's dir?
Ja, es ist wunderschön.
Und warum
bist du drei Jahre hiergeblieben?
Schau dich hier um
und du verstehst es.
Wegen der Schönheit
oder wegen der Geister?
Wegen der Schönheit. Und einige
interpretieren es auch als Geister.
Warum auch nicht?
Jedem seine Weltanschauung.
Glaubst du denn an die Schamanen,
die Energien, die Rituale?
Ich glaube daran.
Ich nehme das ernst.
Aber ich weiss,
das ist nicht meine Kultur.
Es ist da. Ich respektiere das.
Ich habe vielleicht
keinen Zugang zu dieser Welt,
aber ich weiss, dass sie existiert.
Diese Insel
zieht aussergewöhnliche Menschen an.
Deshalb sind wir hier.
Wunderbar.
Christof!
- Hä?
Nicolas Pernot reicht es nicht,
die Schönheit und Kraft
dieses Ortes zu spüren.
Er hält sie immer wieder fest -
in seinen Bildern,
die er von Olchon macht,
über die Jahre
und Jahreszeiten hinweg.
* Majestätische Klänge *
An unserem Nordkap taucht plötzlich
wie aus dem Nichts jemand auf.
Guten Tag,
sind Sie ein Einheimischer?
Wie soll ich sagen -
fast einheimisch, aus Irkutsk.
Ah.
Du hast ein Weibergesicht.
- Was hab ich?
Das ist, wenn ein Mann
ein Gesicht hat wie eine Frau.
Früher war es eine Schande,
sich zu rasieren.
Soll man sich nicht rasieren?
Sicher soll man sich nicht rasieren,
wer hat sich früher rasiert?
Heute zwingt man alle dazu.
- Das erzähle ich meiner Frau.
Sie sagt, ein bisschen Bart
gehe schon, aber nicht zu viel.
Das sind Kosmi. Kosmos!
Je länger die Haare, desto besser
ist die Antenne zum Kosmos.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Ja, es gibt besondere Menschen
auf dieser Insel.
Und auch noch ungewöhnliche Autos.
Z.B. Nicolas' sowjetischen UAZ-Jeep.
So einen
wollte ich immer schon mal fahren.
Ah!
- Voila, voila, vas-y! En avant!
Nach vorn! Pass auf, die Geschwin-
digkeit zu regulieren, ist schwer.
Oh, putain!
* Knarzen *
Jetzt in den zweiten Gang.
Das ist cool.
Dieses Auto passt mir irgendwie.
* Christof lacht. *
Am nächsten Tag ist es so weit:
Ich muss in den Baikalsee,
wenn ich länger leben will.
Das zumindest
sagen die Einheimischen.
Sie sprechen vom heiligen Meer.
Auch so eine magische Kraft,
die dieser Ort haben soll.
16 °C kalt soll er sein,
hat man mir gesagt.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Uiuiui.
Schön.
Das war schön.
Ist er so heilig, wie er kalt ist,
ist er sehr heilig. Nein, wunderbar.
Er ist jeden Tag im Sommer
mit seinem Brett auf dem Baikal.
Für ihn ist es klar,
dass der Baikal heilig ist.
Für Viktor, den Buddhisten.
Ihn hat meine Kollegin Corinne
ein paar Wochen zuvor begleitet.
Viktor macht Ausflüge für Touristen
zur Insel Ogoi.
Dort steht ein buddhistisches
Heiligtum, eine Stupa.
1 Std. stehen die Touristen dafür
mit dem Stand-up-Paddle
auf dem Baikalsee.
Der Weg nach Ogoi
ist ein schwieriger.
Wenn wir zur Stupa gehen,
braucht es einen meditativen
Zustand, eine innere Ruhe.
Wir kontrollieren unseren Atem.
Die Touristen entscheiden selber, wie
viel ihnen die Exkursion wert ist.
Viktor will ein Erlebnis vermitteln,
den Baikal spürbar machen.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Das kann man nicht beschreiben,
das muss man einfach fühlen.
Das ist vollkommene Ruhe,
vollkommene Stille,
vollkommene Zufriedenheit.
Du verschmilzt mit dem Moment.
Du bist ganz im Hier und Jetzt.
Nach 1 Std. am Ufer von Ogoi.
Für den Buddhismus hat sich Viktor
erst als Erwachsener entschieden.
Auch er ist während der Sowjetzeit
als Atheist aufgewachsen
und hat sich erst später
mit Religionen auseinandergesetzt.
Vor vier Jahren hat Viktor
seine Zelte in Olchon aufgeschlagen.
Im Sommer lebt er hier,
zusammen mit einigen Touristen.
Das entspricht ihm viel mehr als
das Grossstadtleben seiner Kindheit.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Du siehst hier echte Emotionen.
Nicht wie bei den Stadtmenschen,
die lügen und betrügen.
Die Leute fangen hier auf Olchon an,
sich zu öffnen.
In der Stadt sind sie verschlossen
und machen sinnlose Sachen.
Sie spielen dort
irgendwelche sozialen Rollen,
die ihnen im Moment wichtig sind.
Und hier werden sie sie selber.
Mit dem Brett auf den See:
Viktor hat seinen Kraftort gefunden.
"Geh ins Dorfmuseum", hat mir
eine einheimische Frau empfohlen.
Da könne ich mehr erfahren
über die eigenartigen Dinge,
die auf dieser Insel
geschehen sollen.
Zuerst erfahre ich etwas
über die Geschichte der Insel:
Olchon
war einst ein Kosakenstützpunkt,
unter Stalin ein Gefangenenlager
und bis in die 90er-Jahre
ein Fischereikombinat.
Dann präsentiert mir
Kapitolina Litwinowa,
die ehemalige Museumsdirektorin,
ihre Lieblingsecke.
Schauen Sie hier in dieser Vitrine,
welche Utensilien wir haben.
Diese gehörten einst
einer Schamanin.
Nach ihrem Tod
wurde die Schamanin verbrannt,
aber ihre Sachen, diese hier,
wurden eingesammelt.
Das war vor 140 Jahren.
Der Geist dieser Schamanin,
sagt uns Kapitolina Litwinowa,
besuche aber regelmässig das Museum.
Dafür gebe es Zeugen.
Der Geist der Schamanin
wurde schon mehrmals gesehen.
Einmal waren z.B. ein paar junge
Frauen in der Nähe des Museums,
die früher noch
über diese Geschichten lachten.
Sie sahen, wie eine Frau, die
auf der Treppe vor dem Museum sass,
plötzlich aufstand und durch
die verriegelte Tür hindurchging.
Es ist tatsächlich so geschehen.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie man das erklären kann,
ich habe solches erlebt, obwohl
es sich wie ein Märchen anhört.
Und so erzählt sie mir 1 Std. lang
eine Geistergeschichte
nach der anderen.
Die heutige Direktorin hat eine
Erklärung für all diese Geschichten.
In all den Jahren der Sowjetmacht
wurde ja praktisch
der totale Atheismus gepredigt.
Die Menschen
haben an nichts Höheres geglaubt.
In all diesen Jahren des Verbotes
haben aber die Glaubensrichtungen
wie Buddhismus und Schamanismus
im Innern immer mehr Energie
aufgesaugt und angesammelt.
Und nach dem Sowjetende begannen
die Menschen wieder zu glauben.
Jetzt ist die Kraft des Schamanismus
viel stärker,
die ganze Energie,
die sich in der Erde gesammelt hat,
wird jetzt
noch viel stärker zurückgegeben.
Beeindruckend, wie die zwei gebilde-
ten Damen ihre Geschichten erzählen.
Sie tun es so überzeugend,
dass man ihnen
eigentlich gerne glauben möchte.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Timo. - Timo. Das ist ...
Und der Familienname?
Jost. J-O-S-T.
- Jost, okay.
Timo ist ein Sinnsuchender
aus der Schweiz.
Heute war ich unten beim Schamanen-
felsen und wollte meditieren,
aber es war sehr unruhig. Ich bin
fast nicht angekommen. - Aha.
Timo scheint mit seinen 21 Jahren
schon eine feine spirituelle Ader
zu haben.
Die Spiritualität ist halt ...
Eine schwierige Frage.
Aber sicher spannend.
- Ja.
Sieh mal an. Das ist er jetzt also.
Timo kennt sich schon aus
auf der Insel
und zeigt uns
d i e  Kraftquelle der Schamanen:
den Schamanenfelsen,
genannt Schamanka.
Ah, alle da.
Mittlerweile
auch ein Touristenmagnet.
Was war dein Ziel,
als du hierher kamst?
Ich sagte mir grundsätzlich,
ich wolle wieder ...
Im Alltag hast du oft nicht viel
Zeit, um dir selber nah zu sein,
zu ... Ich weiss auch nicht.
Zeit für das, was man braucht.
Um vielleicht auch weiterzukommen
als Mensch.
Ich dachte, ich möchte die Reise
äusserlich wie auch innerlich sehen.
Aha.
- Dass es beides ist.
* Schnelle, sphärische Klänge *
Mit meinen Russischkenntnissen
helfe ich Timo,
seiner spirituellen Neugier
nachzugehen.
Wir suchen zusammen
einen Schamanen für ihn.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Am Telefon wirkt er kurz angebunden
und nicht gerade priesterlich.
* Er spricht russisch. *
Der ist etwas böse.
Bei dem musst du aufpassen.
Der treibt dir die guten Geister aus
und lässt die bösen da.
Und wenn er
nach dem Ziel des Rituals fragt?
Wenn er ein Ritual
mit mir machen möchte,
dann sag einfach ... etwas Einfaches
oder Normales. - Aha.
Das ist er wohl.
Michael? Ah, guten Tag. Wir sind es.
Christof.
Siehst du den Abstand
von dieser Linie zu dieser?
Der Abstand ist ein ganzer Finger.
* Er spricht russisch. *
Du spürst gut, ob jemand ein guter
oder schlechter Mensch ist,
hast ein gutes Gespür.
- Für solches schon.
Du könntest morgen zu ihm, um zu
reden, er hat eine Schamanenjurte.
Okay, danke schön.
Morgen um 9 Uhr.
Du kannst sagen,
wenn du es dir anders überlegst
oder in der Nacht
auf einmal das Gefühl hast ...
Dann kann man es
immer noch abblasen.
Ja, ich überlege es mir.
* Mystische Klänge *
Timo will das Experiment wagen.
Kennen Sie den Schamanen Michael?
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Er hat gesagt,
das sei ein ehemaliger Polizist.
Ja.
Aber er hat gesagt, er wisse nicht,
ob er eine Gabe hat oder nicht.
Ja. Das weiss man nicht.
Hast du das Handy ausgemacht? Tu's!
"Filmen verboten", hat er gesagt.
30 Min. lang stellt der Schamane
Timo verschiedene Fragen
zu seinem Befinden
und seinem Lebenslauf.
Er findet aber nichts Spezifisches,
das er behandeln sollte.
Deshalb
macht er ein allgemeines Ritual.
* Michael singt. *
Er singt für Timo und will ihm so
Energie mit auf den Weg geben.
Timo gibt ihm dafür 20 Euro.
Wie fandest du es?
Ich ... Ich habe das Gefühl,
es ist oft so, dass sie ...
Sie behalten das Gesicht so,
damit du's nicht ganz verstehst.
Ich glaube, das ist relativ normal.
- Aha.
Aber dass er das Handy
auf dem Tisch liess
und parallel dazu ...
seine Baustelle organisiert ...
Da sind wir dann schnell
recht kritisch. - Ja.
Ich kenne das -
dass man die Distanz verliert.
Für mich ist es so:
Wenn ich innerlich leer bin,
dehnt sich das ... Dann ist wie ...
Der physische Körper
löst sich fast auf - nicht konkret,
aber die Distanzen gehen völlig
verloren. Und das war hier auch so.
Aber hat es sich gelohnt?
Ich fand es schon noch spannend.
Was dachtest du?
Das mit dem Ritual
fand ich noch eindrücklich. - Ja.
Also die Stimme.
Das hat schon etwas Meditatives.
Und doch: Diesem Schamanen
hätte ich meine Seele nicht geöffnet.
Meine Kollegin Corinne
hatte die besondere Gelegenheit,
in Ulan-Ude
ein Schamanenritual zu filmen.
Eines,
das nicht für Touristen bestimmt ist.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Schamanin Radna soll
in der Gemeinschaft der Schamanen
einen höheren Rang erreichen.
Dafür muss sie eine Prüfung bestehen.
Ich bin sehr aufgeregt.
Ich mache das Ritual,
um mehr Energie zu bekommen.
Es ist schwer, das zu erklären.
Für das Ritual muss sie ein Schaf
nach alter Tradition
als Opfergabe präparieren.
Dass Radna eine Schamanin ist,
entdeckte ihr spiritueller Meister
vor sieben Jahren
und brachte sie
in diese Gemeinschaft.
Später
hat sie in ihrem Familienstammbaum
bis neun Generationen zurück
Schamanen gefunden.
Rund um den Baikalsee
wird schon seit der Steinzeit
Schamanismus praktiziert,
sagen Archäologen.
Noch ein paar Details,
dann können wir morgen anfangen.
Je näher die Prüfung kommt,
desto mehr fürchte ich mich.
Mir kommen fast schon die Tränen.
Schamanen verehren verschiedene Na-
turgeister und beschwören ihre Ahnen.
In den nächsten zwei Tagen
wird sich Radna
dutzende Male
in Trance versetzen müssen.
* Rhythmisches Trommeln, Gesang *
Beim Ritual dabei sind ihre Eltern
und 20 Verwandte und Bekannte.
Und natürlich
ihr spiritueller Schamanenmeister.
* Rhythmisches Trommeln, Gesang *
Radna singt
und trommelt sich in Trance.
Sie verwendet keine
bewusstseinsverändernden Substanzen.
* Schnelles Trommeln, wilder Gesang *
* Radna gibt tiefe Laute von sich. *
Radna ist in Trance gefallen.
Sie ist in Kontakt mit einem Ahnen -
offenbar mit einem Raucher, denn sie
ist eigentlich Nichtraucherin.
Am Anfang ist es sehr schwierig,
viele werden müde.
Man wird auf eine harte Probe
gestellt. Der Körper wird schwer.
Da muss man durch, dann wird
der Körper leicht und schwerelos.
Und man darf den Moment
nicht verpassen.
Es ist wie ein Korridor, in dem es
hell wird. Durchsichtig und leicht.
Aber das können normale Menschen
nicht verstehen.
Bis tief in die Nacht hinein
praktiziert Radna Ritual um Ritual,
fällt in Trance und kontaktiert
einen Vorfahren nach dem anderen.
Am nächsten Morgen:
der Höhepunkt der Prüfung.
Ihre Freunde und Verwandten
haben vor Ort übernachtet,
sie bleiben während des Rituals
immer zusammen bei Radna.
* Rhythmischer Gesang *
Radna trägt nun eine besondere Weste
und muss nochmals in Trance fallen.
Die Weste
ist extra für sie angefertigt
und wiegt 40 kg,
fast so viel wie Radna selbst.
Noch nie hat sie eine solche Last
bei einem Ritual getragen.
Wird sie die Prüfung bestehen?
Gelingt es ihr, nicht aus der Trance
zu fallen? Nicht zusammenzubrechen?
* Lauter Gesang,
rhythmisches Trommeln *
* Das Trommeln wird schneller
und hört dann abrupt auf. *
* Radna gibt tiefe Laute von sich. *
* Glöckchenbimmeln *
* Beruhigende Rufe *
Die Prüfung ist bestanden. Jetzt kann
sie als Heilerin noch mehr bewirken.
Sie sagt, dass sie die Last während
des Rituals nicht gespürt habe -
zur Freude ihres Lehrers.
Sehen Sie, vor Glück hatte ich
sogar die Jacke ausgezogen.
Mir ist so heiss geworden.
Am Abend
gibt es ein grosses Festmahl.
Wir freuen uns,
dieses grosse Fest zu feiern.
Und dass meine Ahnen
die Opfergaben angenommen haben.
Und natürlich, dass ich die Prüfung
mit Bravour bestanden habe.
* Sie sprechen burjat. *
Journalistenkollegen
hatten geschrieben,
es gebe rund um den Baikalsee
keine echten Schamanen mehr.
Ich selber würde mir
am Ende dieser Reise
kein abschliessendes Urteil zutrauen.
Den meisten Menschen, denen ich auf
Olchon begegnet bin, war anzumerken,
dass diese Insel und ihr Glaube
ihnen etwas schenkt.
* Ruhige, tiefe Klänge *
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen,
dass es hier etwas Besonders gibt.
Wenn man vielleicht mit offenem
Herzen käme, das wirken liesse,
vielleicht meditieren
oder sich mehr Zeit nehmen würde.
Und ich habe mir auch überlegt:
Wir haben hier Menschen getroffen,
die offen
über ihre Spiritualität sprechen.
Die Rituale mitmachen
und sagen, was sie gespürt haben.
Oder die auch darüber reden,
was sie suchen.
Vielleicht nehme ich das mit:
Man könnte etwas offener sein,
was die eigene Spiritualität
betrifft.
* Sphärische, meditative Klänge *
In der letzten Folge meiner Russland-
reise will ich ganz hoch hinaus:
auf den Elbrus im Kaukasus.
Mit über 5'600 m ü.M.
der höchste Berg Europas.
Allerdings habe ich von Klettern
und Bergsteigen keine Ahnung.
Eine Herausforderung -
auch für meinen Bergführer Alexej.